[Music]
for new people that don't know frozen is
our producer and um
he's so cute he's such a cutie pie and
he's single
you know what alex is on so we're gonna
have more people watching this hey our
producer frozen nation
hold on our producer frozen asian is a
cutie pie okay and
he's calling me that hold on cutie pie
frozen asian is looking for a lovely
lady anywhere near the toronto area so
if you wanna you know hook up with him
you can find him on twitter at
a frozen asian that's at a frozen asian
and use promo code rotc will give you a
10 discount male or female he doesn't
care
great now i'm gonna get more dick pics
this is not this is not what i did the
live read and now i then i just did a
live read for frozen for get him girls
nice i helped try to help you use promo
code rotc
yeah when you're blowing asian when
you're blowing frozen
and yes that's [ __ ] wonderful
oh
how was your cigarette it was like half
a second i would take it
dab but my i should have told you to get
the paper clip my thing is clogged
yeah you should have told me that why
don't you just smoke on air i normally
well be [ __ ] spiders
are you smoking
i love this
i haven't smoked in 12 years but the
nuclear war is so close i'm serious i
said [ __ ] it and started smoking a month
ago i love this
i love this alex right what's your brand
hell by the way what's your brand
yeah i i like all sorts of good stuff
i'm an american spirits guy myself
this is an american spirit but there you
go hey we smoked the same smokes
that's the point of his kids don't do
this at home you know kids but my point
is is that how much have we been
vindicated about
how much like they admit now the head of
the u.n admits for the censors at
youtube it's now admitted that the head
of the un who ted rose says it probably
came out of the lab and when now they
admit it has like 20 efficacy the the
vaccine if you don't get side effects oh
and and now they've announced world
government and now they and oh first
they said there was no inflation now
they admit there is i mean they just had
a white house official on fox saying
there's no open border yesterday it's
ridiculous no one's buying your big
corporate gas lighting it's not working
anymore so let me ask all you guys we're
preparing for the russian nukes yeah the
land from the submarines or the chinese
ones let's see what i'm gonna do as the
whole establishment is discredited right
now
well i think i think they overreached i
think the problem is alex and you know
they i think they you they they use
remember when they used to lie to us and
they used to try to hide it at least
like they always lied to us right but
they used to pretend like oh no they
used to give us bread and circus
we still had like you know a couple
funny late night hosts you know and you
know we had some some decent movies to
watch at least and then they just
started going you know yeah now they're
like no now you're just gonna get the
best that's why you're not allowed to
smoke in studio is that your wife doing
that uh this is my studio and yes i'm
yeah i smoke in my shoes
but not in my studio we don't smoke we
do well we weed we smoke weed but we
don't we don't have cigarettes but we
had you on today it's a disgusting habit
i think you're right yeah
so by the way this is the best this is i
tell you alex this is my favorite
version of alex jones in my opinion oh
yeah no this is it's just had it alex
hanging out with bonnie rotten shooting
guns eating steaks smoking cigarettes
you know doing yoga and [ __ ] this is
this is i like this alex what are you
what are you drinking there alex had a
curious what kind of what would you are
you going to get like a mclaren soon
maybe or ferrari i don't actually i
don't actually smoke or drink i'm just
acting tough oh he's acting this is
actually a virgin either i haven't had
like a thousand women
i'm just i'm just sitting here acting
cool probably not true the problem is
you smoke too many cigarettes a
cigarette
this is a cg cigarette this is not vodka
and soda hear me out on this uh alex
infowars brand cigarettes yeah we're
talking come on you know no
no harsh additives
if george strait has a tequila i should
have one huh i mean i'm telling you
infowars properly properly grown organic
tobacco leaf hand rolled by indians well
you know tugger carlson's right i don't
normally learn stuff i know a lot of
stuff but the other day i knew that
cigarettes i knew that caffeine
and
nicotine helped you know boost iq while
you're on it and focus clarity and i
know the stuff in the cigarette the
extra tar and stuff is really toxic and
bad kids shouldn't do it way better than
fentanyl which they don't like people
out of jail who have like tons of
fentanyl you can leave the next day i
just saw that article yesterday but
nicotine by itself does boost uh iq and
boost testosterone and i and i i knew it
boosted iq
but i didn't know that it boosted
testosterone and thunder carlson said it
last week i looked it up and what do you
know
it boosts iq well every every like
famous like hemingway and every famous
writer all of them one thing they all
had in common was they're all they're
all heavy smokers yeah right and it
inhibits covet that's true remember it
they they did say that it does
it does it does well it's kind of like
if you don't get a lot of sun you're
going to die of cancer and if you get a
lot of sun you're going to die of cancer
like if you get a lot of sun you have
high d3 high immune system we're meant
to get sun but it also kills you yeah
it's like everything's got its balance
except fentanyl which kills everybody
man i'm really pissed about fentanyl
yeah i personally
know five people that have died from it
the last three years and everybody i
know is people that died and i'm really
pissed they're not prosecuting fentanyl
people weed dealers other stuff don't
give them jail time it's non-criminal
fentanyl people i want your ass drawn
and quartered i want your intestines
strung out on national tv i want these
people executed man i'm pissed i don't
know but biden's banning
e-cigarettes with nicotine but oh
fentanyl's okay i mean i am pissed well
not only uh fentanyl and i think i
brought this up last time you were on um
there's a cousin of fentanyl called
carfentanil which is a hundred times
more powerful than fentanyl it's not
even used medically on yeah because
fentanyl they use on like elephants and
rhinos and [ __ ] carfentanil is just a
biotoxin it basically like there have
been there's been speculation over the
years that they'll eventually use bio
weapons with carfentanil in them because
just a small amount you can aerosolize
it get it in the air you can kill a
stadium full of people it was
declassified in 1990 and reclassified in
99 under the request of the marine corps
but the sunshine project of austin texas
uh which is now a defunct liberal group
of good guys they got the documents via
four year requests from information act
that the pentagon with the marines and
the army have
drone helicopter bases this was in the
90s
drone helicopter bases where a warehouse
opens up a drone helicopter launches
and then it sprays they said a synthetic
version of opiates up to 500 times
stronger that would knock out whole
cities during a martial law scenario
they just found that 10 of the
population would die of car wrecks and
fires
doing it so yes the government does have
drone helicopters as of decades ago in
bunkers loaded with fentanyl oh yeah and
you know what defend all something else
that we could thank big pharma for the
thing we're supposed to worship that's
my other thing about the
good guys
the good guys yeah the good guys created
the same people that create fentanyl and
have people addicted to oxy are telling
you yeah no take our vaccine which by
the way something else alex is weird
that you could add to your jar is about
now they have to come out and said there
is side effects of the vaccine they had
to they just came out there was news
articles that said it is giving bell's
palsy you are getting blood clots and
they had to put it on there and even
johnson and johnson had to stop giving
it out because of how bad it was for
women i was about to say uh
16 and up in europe none of these
experimental shots are even allowed yeah
you're the only country in the world
that did 16 and under and now six months
and up and you try to talk about it they
censor you even though it's true
yeah also i find it to be a very odd
question i want to say
folks fentanyl is good for you cnn does
not lie and the and the coven vaccine is
wonderful and 100 effective you'll live
forever if you take it and see rainbows
perfect don't you don't you find it odd
alex though that the uh the big
pharmaceutical companies all got slapped
with like an earth-shattering amount of
money in a lawsuit and then like a year
later they had an emergency
authorization for facts that made i
don't know just about that exact amount
of money they made a bunch of it made a
bunch of you see the timing seems really
weird that they were like i don't know
has paid
pfizer's paid the biggest fines in
history
j the second largest and then we're
supposed to let them give us something
experimental with no real trials and you
see the fda uh monday
you look this up came out and said you
know we're going to just stop doing
trials all together
yep
for any for any new variance of what say
so they want to be able to to change the
chemical compound of the vaccine and not
have to file for new clinical trials
just change it on the fly and their
excuses well it's faster you know
because they cuz because you know
viruses change very quickly so that was
their excuse for viruses that were made
in the luhan lab which you're allowed to
say now but remember they were telling
us that global warming was going to
cause all these deadly viruses to come
out of the jungles sorry they don't come
out of jungles they come out of
laboratories oh yeah and by the way and
and then china and then china and then
china doesn't release numbers
ford for years and china oh yeah now
they're locking down and welding doors
over there and now people here have to
pretend that they're shocked i'm like
shut up if you had it your way you guys
would have locked us in our homes too
and told us to sit there and order uber
eats until we die
i just got to say i was so relieved to
find out that those that those viruses
were made in a lab because i just
couldn't wait to go back to eating bat
oh yeah
i stopped eating bat for like two months
because i was so paranoid wiping down
you know all the all the handles in the
house and then and then no and it was a
wuhan lab and i went thank god can we
get some bat please you're thinking of a
pangolin
it was a pangolin but the big thing is
you guys are right we have all these
government documents coming out of the
uk and canada and germany and here
they're planning new lockdowns
and two weeks after bill gates with
smallpox eradicated since the 80s goes
smallpox is coming back and then
magically smallpox is back and now
california is talking about new
lockdowns for it i mean this is
incredibly transparent it's almost like
an iq test let's see what we'll put up
with uh live announcement right now
breaking news we are banned on d live
we just got banned on z live that's
hilarious we are
to know who owns the live uh the the
china the chinese owned blockchain the
blockchain [ __ ] one down i don't
care no i know i we we
we use d live as one of our streams but
we barely pay attention to it but yeah
everyone just came over there with
d-live's gone you just got nuked
they don't like you over there alex yeah
like they don't like you the chinese
techno fascists the literal chinese
technofascist youtube doesn't like you
yeah
i'm sorry to hear that we don't
um
that's not very nice though it's not
very neighborly yeah it's not it's not
very nice of d life the bananas i
thought they were one of our allies they
thought we had strong relations with
chelsea speaking of allies alex here's a
question i do have what do you think is
zielinski
i mean zielinski's a total complete
ridiculous actor puppet
they've got him blackmailed because of
all the
risque stuff he's done
and all that ukraine is is a giant money
laundering operation i saw a cartoon
that shows like a building that says
ukraine war and democrats walk bags of
money in they walk bags of money out to
themselves so they've been using ukraine
like israel as a big money laundering
operation for a long time you know we
give aid to israel and it just comes
right back into the hands that give it
but that's what foreign aid's about i
mean
foreign aid taxpayer money's given to
all these countries and then special
considerations are given to key
corporations and groups and individuals
but
it i mean it's come out like that they
just they got it right here wife of
former ukrainian politician caught with
28 million in cash at the hungarian
border and it was all you know u.s
dollars for 20 million 25.
wow but that's okay alex we'll print
more you know we could just break this
can you overhead shot because this is
not just props here you guys bring this
up yeah i mean let me show these
articles overhead shot please yeah oh we
know you've got no crew in there they're
probably documented they're probably all
on fentanyl
you know
it's a problem there in texas it is it's
a big ice pump punch this up yeah
nobody's in the control room
[Music]
ukrainian well it tells you a call with
28 million like 27 million was u.s money
and it's got photos of it all let me let
me show you some photos and then you
know here's photos of the uh suitcases
of cash my god and we got oh look here's
the cartoon i talked about this is
exactly what's happening taxpayer funds
and they go in ukrainian aid and then
members of congress
exactly but like you know don't you find
it like weird because zelinski's
literally a billionaire by the way is a
bunch of offshore corporates yeah and he
has like a ship he has a home like in in
yeah he's a billionaire he's walking
around on a green screen set
and wearing like these t-shirts and he
doesn't own a suit it's like it's like
joe biden and his aviators it's just all
this stuff was like focus grouped and
they it's like they came up with this
image of this dude
i'm wearing aviators liberals put out
memes with him and aviators and go hey
yeah we got inflation we got collapsing
borders and fentanyl death but he's
wearing aviators yeah he falls off bikes
you gotta know he is but he's wearing
aviators hey he's eating ice cream i
also enjoy ice cream he's just like me
it really is the the fact that they try
to make they they try to humanize these
demons
they're like literally demonic
weird stiff like inhuman people don't
feel scared here's the head of nuclear
weights in the u.s
yeah
it's like mars is actually alienware's
address and there it is exactly you
dressed like a character from the fifth
element yes seriously
oh god you know at some point it's like
a beluga whale so look at the head looks
like a belugas but yeah you know what it
looks like actually it looks like a
shaved matt damon a trans matt damon is
what it looks like you know royce and i
have been saying for five years now we
we just live in a shittier version of
robocop yeah that's pretty much what our
lives have become no i agree this is
like the alternate comedy reality
the space aliens go and watch or
our fellow humans yes they're like an
advanced species of humans and they
watch us for entertainment